this is the last GPU that Nvidia will be
launching in 2022 the RTX 4080 and today
I'm benchmarking and reviewing the
founders Edition straight from Nvidia
the costs twelve hundred dollars MSRP
which is a 500 increase over its
predecessor the RTX 3080 which launched
two years ago in 2020 for 700 and I'll
say it right up front while it is true
that RTX 3080s regularly sold for 1200
or more during the Great GPU shortage of
2021 and 2022 that situation is now
behind us and I do not think 500 is a
reasonable increase from one generation
to the next I want to say positive
things about the technological advances
that Nvidia has made with the RTX 4080 I
want to praise the performance increases
say I am pleasantly surprised with the
power draw and temperatures and discuss
the benefits of dlss 3.0 but it's all
tarnished and overshadowed by the stupid
stupid price and yes you can absolutely
make justifications for a 1200 RTX 4080
if you own Nvidia stock I suppose but
historically advances in PC Hardware
performance were largely passed down to
Consumers whereas now Nvidia really
really seems to view gpus as a commodity
that they need to price as high as the
market will bear and again shareholders
yes you got to get yours business is
business but if my enthusiasm for this
launch is dampened as well as the
enthusiasm of what I think is a pretty
big slice of the PC gaming Community who
can't afford to pay upwards of a grand
for a GPU well that's the reason why
excellent
today's video is brought to you by
g-skill ddr5 memory I've been using
g-skill RAM and PC builds and high
performance test systems for over a
decade now and they are constantly
pushing out Sleek new designs and faster
kits with tighter timings give your
build a colorful highlight with the
Trident Z5 RGB line or be assured of
Maximum compatibility with the XMP
enabled rip Jaws S5 series for Intel
12th and 13th gen CPUs or the Expo
enabled flare X5 line optimized for
amd's new am5 platform for more on G
skills ddr5 memory kits click the
sponsor Link in the video description
okay so for what it's worth I'm going to
attempt to set aside my disappointments
about the price of this card and focus
on performance until I come back to the
summary at the end my review is
separated into three parts and there are
timestamps you can jump ahead if you
wish first we have the performance of
the hardware itself clock speeds
temperatures and power draw secondly we
have the raw frame rate results for old
school game rasterization benchmarks and
thirdly we have a light smattering of
dlss 3.0 testing to see how frame
generation works with the RTX 4080 and
once again comparing the RTX 4080 to a
stacked deck of what were previously the
most powerful cards in the world from
AMD and Nvidia from Team Green we have
the RTX 4090 represented by the Nvidia
Founders Edition the RTX 39dti
represented by the manufacturer
overclocked MSI Supreme X the RTX 3090
also represented by the Nvidia Founders
Edition and the RTX 3080 TI once again
in Nvidia Founders Edition trim and from
team red we have their top GPU at least
until December 13th the RX 6950xt
represented by the gigabyte gaming OC
16g and lastly the RX 6900 XT which uses
the AMD reference design if you would
like to shamelessly Ogle the RTX 4080
Founders Edition card itself here are
some closer shots note that it looks
pretty much exactly like the RTX 4090
except for the text it says RTX 4080
it's the same size and everything it has
a 320 watt tgp or total Graphics power
rating but does still require a 750 watt
power supply at minimum as well as three
8-pin PCI Express Graphics power
connectors to feed the 12 VH power
dongle that's included in the Box
there's one HDMI 2.1 and 3 DisplayPort
1.4 a connectors for video outs
unfortunately no DisplayPort 2.1 like
the upcoming RX 7900 XT and XTX will
have and yes it is still absolutely
massive because it is the same size as
the RTX 4090 requiring three slots in
your case at minimum the GPU itself is
the Ada Lovelace ad103 300 A1 chip built
on tsmc's 4N lithography and supporting
9728 Cuda cores a big step down from the
16 384 cores and the 4090 the 4080 also
has a 2505 megahertz boost clock and 16
gigabytes of gddr6x memory that can hit
22.4 gigabits per second despite having
less bandwidth versus its Big Brother
relevant stats for all the cards tested
today are here if you want to pause to
compare them and do note that I'm
showing current pricing based on the
average of the cheapest three to four
models available on PC part picker and
while these prices have come down
significantly in recent months I've
noted that just recently some of the
Nvidia gpus have bounced and are back on
the upswing moving on to my test setup
all tests were run on this test system
with an Asus RG x670e Crosshair hero
motherboard and a ryzen 97950x 16 core
CPU cooled back Corsair 360 millimeter
AIO memory is a 32 gigabyte g-skill
Trident Z5 Neo ddr5 6000cl30 kit the
same one from my recent ryzen 7000 CPU
reviews and for power we have a Corsair
ax 1600i 1600 watt ATX power supply
tests were run on Windows 11 version 21
H2 and here are stats for the rest of
the system if you'd like to take a
closer look let's move on to Performance
though and here are the clock speeds I
was seeing out of the cards while in use
the RTX 4080 boosted well beyond its
advertised clock speeds as well as the
RTX 4090 hitting 2820 megahertz Peak and
averaging around 2 800 megahertz under a
typical gaming workload it's a notable
generational leap in frequencies and
until the RX 7900s launch it gives
Nvidia the frequency crown for now but
frequencies are only one component of
GPU perform performance here are my Peak
GPU core and memory temperatures and
there's some very good news for Mini ITX
system Builders the 4080s 320 watt total
Graphics power and likely the use of a
smaller ad103 die versus the RTX 4090
meant the recorded temperatures were the
lowest of any card in my Roundup
including the third-party triple fan
coolers from the RTX 390 TI and rx6950xt
for anyone who gave up on fitting nrtx
4090 into a small form factor build a
4080 should be much more reasonable
let's round this part out with my power
draw numbers and here's another good
result for NVIDIA 460 Watts average
system power draw is also the lowest in
this Roundup apart from the RX 6900 XT
again demonstrating the efficiency gains
achieved through architectural
improvements and moving from Samsung 8
nanometer lithography to tsmc's N4 node
and now it is time for traditional
rasterization benchmarks at 4K 1440 and
1080p let's dive in 3D Mark time spy
extremist first which is a 4K test and a
graphic score of over 14 000 and it
would seem more impressive or Not
dwarfed by the 19277 points that the RTX
4090 achieved it's still outperforming
the best card from the 30 series though
staying 23 percent ahead of the 39 DTI
as well as maintaining a 37 lead over
the 6950 XT but please note that this is
a synthetic Benchmark so it's not
included in My overall numbers 3dmark
Port Royal is my other synthetic
Benchmark from 3dmark so we can get a
general idea of how these cards handle
Ray tracing here's a trend that will
continue today the 4080 is 30 slower
than the 4090 and 22 percent faster than
the 3090 TI it'll stay between these two
cards for most of these tests but is
closer to the 3090 TI than to the 4090
and yes the Radeon 6000 cards still suck
at Ray tracing moving on to real world
games we have a lot of DirectX 12 titles
starting with Far Cry 6 we're at 4K the
4080 extended a healthy lead over the
3090 TI again getting 109.6 FPS on
average which is about 18 ahead although
it's still 27 slower than the 40 90.
those one percent lows do look good here
though at 1440 we begin to hit CPU
limitations and the 4080 manages to just
barely outpace the 6950 XT and 3090 TI
it also remains about 4.9 percent slower
than the RTX 4090 at 1080p we are pretty
much entirely CPU bound as you can see
with only a two to three percent
difference between each card but the
4080 lands at the bottom of the pack
down 5.5 percent versus the 4090 next we
have Shadow of the Tomb Raider and yes
the trend you may note is that at 4K
we're looking more directly at the
performance of each graphics card
whereas at 1440 and 1080 the CPU
limitations begin to even things out 160
FPS on average for the RTX 4080 is 17.6
percent ahead of the 39 DTI and 27
percent slower than the 4090. at 1440
the 4080 beats the 3090 TI again but
it's only three percent ahead while
being 8.4 percent slower than the RTX
4090 but one percent lows for both 40
series cards were down versus the other
gpus at 1080p we are our CPU Bound Again
with the 3090 TI and 6950 XT managing
the best results for Team Green and team
red and the 4080 Landing in last place
cyberpunk 2077 is running with the ultra
Graphics preset which is a challenge at
4K but the 4080s still managed 70.3 FPS
on average and one percent lows that
were better than all of the other cards
that were tested at 1440 the 4080 hit
131 FPS putting it 19.5 percent ahead of
the 39 DTI and 17 behind the 4090 and at
1080p we are CPU bound again but not
quite so much with the 4090 maintaining
its position at 185.7 FPS besting the
390 TI by 17 here's Horizon zero Dawn
using the favor quality preset and at
the risk of repeating myself the 4080
has another healthy 9 lead over the 3090
TI at 4K while it's also behind the 4090
once again by 25 percent the lead is
increased at 1440 with the 4080s 218 FPS
being 13 in front of the 3090 TI while
remaining 7.2 percent behind the 40 90.
at 1080 things have evened out a lot as
we become CPU bound and the 4080 picks
up a rare but modest win over the 4090
while barely edging out the 6950 XT by
1.5 percent continuing on to dirt 5 the
anti-concrete racing game we're running
the ultra high preset at 4K goddess
136.4 FPS out of the RTX 4080 another 13
Victory versus the 3090 TI that also
puts it 29 slower than the 4090. at 1440
we see a bit of a boost in relative
performance the 4080 is now 20 ahead of
the 39 DTI and 24 percent slower than
the 4090 and at 1080 the margins shrink
a bit but not too much 264 FPS from the
4080 means a 19.9 percent win versus
3090 TI and a loss of 15.6 percent
compared to the 4090 next up is Resident
Evil Village another DirectX 12 game
with scary vampires and stuff the 4080
pushed out 161 FPS at 4K for another 20
win over the 3090 TI while staying 27
behind the 40 90. Radeon gpus typically
perform form well with this game but
despite that they still could not touch
the 4080 it's 22 and 28 ahead of the
6950 XT and 6900 XT here at 1440. and
even here at 1080 the Radeon 6000s
surpassed the 3090 TI but still land
behind the 4080 which was 4.7 percent
ahead of the 6950 XT and 6.9 ahead of
the 6900 XT Doom Eternal is my only
Vulcan title but it makes up for that
with demon splattering action and
maximum frame rates starting at 4K the
4080 pushed over 275 frames per second
sure not quite the 365 FPS that the 4090
managed but still adequate for those
upcoming 4k 240Hz displays depending on
the video of connection you have I guess
and a 17 win over the 3090 TI at 1440 we
have a similar lineup but slightly
simmer margins but now the RTX 4080 is
hitting just shy of 500 frames per
second so bring on the 1440p 480 Hertz
refresh rate monitors I would say if the
RTX 4080 had displayed for two point 0.1
it doesn't so 240 hertz at 1440p is the
best you can do and 120 hertz at 4K for
anyone wondering and then at 1080p we
get up to 563 frames per second with the
4080 putting at 17.6 percent ahead of
the 3090 TI and 9.5 behind the 4090.
lastly we have a couple DirectX 11
titles here is God of War we're at 4K
the 4080s lead is less comfortable than
the 4090s at 101.6 FPS on average it's
about 16 percent ahead of the 3090 TI
and 21 slower than the 40 90. at 1440
the 4080 is between the 4090 and the
3090 TI yet again still 20 ahead of the
3090 TI and about 14 behind the 4090 at
1080p we have reasonable scaling and
minimal CPU limitations placing the RTX
4080 16.4 percent in front of the 39 DTI
and 15.5 percent slower than the 4090.
lastly we have Microsoft flight
simulator running in DirectX 11 mode and
exhibiting some of the worst CPU
bottlenecking in my tests although it is
least noticeable at 4K 4080 manages a 21
win over the 3090 TI while staying about
10 percent behind the 40 90. at 1440
though we hit that CPU wall with the
Nvidia cards and the 4080 and 4090 get
passed up by the 30 series cards with
the 3090 TI on top and then at 1080 the
6950 and 6900 XT pull up to take the win
which is not a significant one at this
point but team red will take what they
can get also a low note for the 4080 to
end on but it's a good segue into some
dlss 3.0 testing what if there was a way
to circumvent these CPU limitations in a
game like flight simulator dlss is now
upgraded to version 3 with the debut of
nvidia's rtx40 series which provides
more performance and higher frame rates
with some degree of loss in visual
Fidelity the RTX 4080 and 4090 feature
4th gen tensor cores for dlss and 3rd
gen RT cores for retracing but perhaps
the most compelling new feature is frame
generation which uses AI to create new
frames that are inserted in in between
traditionally rendered ones I recommend
the hardware unboxed dlss 3.0 Deep dive
video for some pixel peeping comparisons
and further explanations of the
technology but for today I have some
quick testing to see what kind of a
boost we get using the new RTX 4080
starting with cyberpunk 2077 we have
cranked settings up to the ray traced
Ultra preset which is barely playable
using traditional rasterization even
with the 4080 averaging below 30 frames
per second dlss 3.0 by itself boosts
that to 76.3 FPS on average and this is
in performance mode which is recommended
at 4K image quality is still right in
line with the native 4K definition and
then by turning on frame generation we
boost the frame rate to 112.7 about a
290 percent increase in frames versus
native and a 48 boost compared to frame
generation being off with little to no
noticeable impact on the visuals that's
a great result and something Nvidia
should be proud of here's another test
with flight simulator a bit of a poster
child for this technology given the CPU
limitations I discussed during during
the benchmarks dlss 3.0 alone doesn't
help flight simulator very much only
providing about 2.5 more frames per
second but frame generation jumps that
number from 72.7 up to 142.2 nearly
doubling the frame rate at close to a
100 percent Improvement of course as
mentioned in the hardware unboxed video
the AI generated frames aren't always
perfect but I think flight Sim fans will
gladly make the trade given just how
drastic this frame rate jump is okay
time for my overall results skipping to
this part of the video is a great idea
even though it brings with it a terrible
curse I'm just kidding of course here
are my overall numbers evenly weighted
by game using the RTX 3090 Founders
Edition as the 100 Baseline to sum up
the RTX 4080 provides a significant
performance boost over the best that
last gen could muster 33 better than the
3090 at 4K 25.3 percent faster at 1440
and 14.6 percent ahead at 1080. it's in
front of the 3090 TI 2 by roughly the
same amounts minus 10 or so all while
drawing less power and maintaining lower
temps versus the best cards from the 30
series here's that same data alongside
current pricing for these cards and
while discounts have made these Elite
tier gpus more affordable they're still
all in the one thousand dollar range for
nvidia's offerings that's a lot to spend
on just a GPU and it brings me back to
my frustrations from the intro just as
they did with the RTX 20 series when it
debuted Nvidia is stacking the 40 series
cards on top of their existing offerings
at higher prices rather than replacing
cards lowered down in the lineup and so
to conclude that's the thing distracting
me from thoroughly praising the RTX 4080
pricing both practically speaking for
gamers who just can't afford it and from
the standpoint of principle PC parts
have a long history of getting better
and faster over time and those
technological advances have historically
been largely shared with consumers yes
prices go up but they go up some while
performance goes up a lot and here's a
good exam example incidentally it was
the first one that I looked for the GTX
980 and 80 class card launched for 550
bucks back in September of 2014 and just
shy of two years later its successor the
GeForce GTX 1080 launched in May 2016.
for 600 bucks more expensive yes by nine
percent sounds reasonable and I would
say it was especially when you consider
that the performance increased by about
51 percent with the 1080 according to
tech power up there might be a little
bit of variance there but we're talking
ballpark but that is significantly more
than the nine percent increase in costs
this made PC Builders and consumers
excited because they were getting more
for their money now Nvidia just wants to
say look it's 20 to 30 percent faster so
we increased the price 20 percent and
that's being generous by using the 3090
with current pricing when Jensen claims
that Moore's Law is dead it's a very
calculated thing to say because the
steady and advance of Moore's Law is
what allowed for significantly more
performance with each generation of PC
technology and he'd rather charge us for
those improvements based on the
performance results rather than the
actual increases in their manufacturing
costs but there it is hopefully now you
guys have a much better idea of how the
RTX 4080 Stacks up and I will say I am
impressed with the technology and the
performance and the temperatures and
even the power draw just very
disappointed in the price but that's all
for this review closing reminder to
check out my store at paulsharbor.net
for merchandise shirts pint glasses and
other thumb screw related items
including these water bottles which are
now in stock as requested many times by
many different people since I've been
showing them on my channel and of course
you can hit the like button if you
enjoyed this video And subscribe to my
channel if you really enjoyed it thanks
as always for watching and we'll see you
guys in the next video foreign
[Music]